it's perfect
you don't really think of goats and
cookies together do you
my husband he says it's because they're
satanic goats
i don't even think the devil eats
cookies does he
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
about the first part of ozark season
four which was just released on netflix
because this is part one of two that
will make up the final season it seemed
unlikely that the birds would get out
from under the cartel but they were so
close because marty is extremely good at
what he does and wendy has now gone full
heisenberg it was necessary to introduce
some new characters to derail their
plans and to add some internal conflict
in the family with jonah changing sides
and deciding to work with ruth and
darlene we saw how one of those new
characters javi undermined their chance
to get free and clear during part one
and saw the other a private investigator
named mel satom emerged to probably
serve a similar role in part two i'll be
getting into all of that plus what
happened at the end right after this
quick spoiler warning if you haven't
watched all seven episodes of ozark
season 4 part 1 then this video won't be
for you and with that out of the way
let's get into it
i do want to mention that the season
starts with a flash forward to the
entire family together in the minivan
where they all seem to be getting along
there's talk of 48 more hours and
calling for the moving company but a
truck veers into their lane and when
they swerve to avoid it they crash
rolling the van on the side of the road
we never revisit this scene in the seven
episodes that follow so what's going on
here and when it happens remains a
question mark the present storyline
picks up right after the season 3 finale
and i mean right after as in the birds
have yet to wash helen's brains out of
their hair after they do that we meet
omar navarro's nephew javier alessandro
aka hobby and learned that he's
well-spoken and eager to play a larger
role in running the family business he
went to university in chicago and was
close with helen and later says that he
voted to kill them instead of her when
that came up he also brings up darlene
snell which means that the birds are now
tasked with getting her to shut down her
operation and later navarro backs him up
on this he explains that if he shows any
weakness javi could make a move to try
to take over he also tells the birds
that he wants them to set up a deal with
their fbi contacts he'll give up his
cartel but he wants to be able to move
freely between the us and mexico and
he's essentially looking for immunity
for all of his crimes they tell him that
there's no way that they can make that
happen and he reminds them that they
don't really have a choice the bright
side is that if they pull it off they'll
be free of their obligation to him and
that sets up what they have to try to do
for the rest of the season after ben's
death at the end of season three ruth
langmore stopped working for marty and
threw in with darlene and her cousin
wyatt at the beginning of season 4 she
buys the lazy o motel to launder their
money and this is where we first met her
and her cousins when the birds came to
town in season one she's got a problem
though she knows how to run marty's
laundering software but doesn't know how
to make her own this is what will
eventually lead to her teaming up with
jonah who's developed software at age 14
which is impressive even if the actor
has outgrown his role in the past couple
of years he's still upset about learning
from helen that his parents had been
killed and after wendy decides to take
the hard approach in trying to bend him
to her will he goes full team ruth for
all seven episodes on the other hand
charlotte is completely on board with
the family business and has even decided
she's going straight into it rather than
going to college beyond reaching out to
wyatt and threatening helen's daughter
erin at one point they don't give her
much to do in these episodes but i
couldn't help noticing that the actor
made a real attempt to copy some allure
lenny's mannerisms which shows how much
she's starting to take after her mother
helen's disappearance has brought
another new character to town mel is a
private investigator that says he was
hired by her husband to get her
signature on divorce paperwork he has a
habit of showing up at inopportune times
and after observing the birds for a
while he starts to believe that ben
might have been involved with helen's
disappearance of course ben is dead so
he's barking up the wrong tree but he
may turn out to be a real problem for
marty and wendy when they looked into
his past they learned that he was a cop
that was really good at his job before
his substance abuse issues led to him
getting caught in the evidence room and
losing his badge for most of the season
wendy is making big moves in her attempt
to turn them into one of the most
powerful families in the midwest and
that includes working with a
pharmaceutical company whose reputation
has taken a hit for their role in
helping to create the opioid crisis that
helped her put together a 150 million
dollar war chest after she stole jim out
from under charles wilks and made him
their full-time attorney i compared her
to walter white earlier because this has
completed her transformation that
started back in season 2. it's clear
this has all gone to her head and she
makes two questionable decisions that
will make things difficult for the
family going forward the first was to
use her brother ben for what she says is
good pr saying that he had a drug
problem and using the fact that he's
missing to her advantage this causes
problems with marty and with ruth and
that brings darlene into things to try
to stick up for wyatt's cousin the
second is that she tries to force jonah
into coming back to the family and when
that doesn't work she goes as far as
trying to get him arrested by the time
we get to episode 7 marty has mostly
been able to neutralize javi whose uncle
is actively working on a deal with the
fbi behind his back he had convinced
navarro to give maya information that
would lead to seizures to keep her happy
and that worked until hobby rigged one
of those with a bomb this led to navarro
deciding to give him up he told him that
he was stepping aside and that he'd be
the new boss and then set a meeting with
the fbi jim is on hand to explain all of
that and that omar will provide the
necessary information to neutralize his
cartel entirely the problem there is
that the fbi has been enjoying the extra
money they've been getting through those
cash seizures and have decided that they
want him to continue being a drug lord
for five more years after that they can
grant him immunity from prosecution in
the u.s since he's already told hobby
that he was taking over it means that he
would have to kill him and the fbi knows
that and they're okay with that maya is
not okay with it though she can't
believe what she's hearing and her boss
has to explain that they're trying to
collaborate as a way to make progress
and that she has to think about the big
picture because if they take navarro
down someone else will just rise up to
take his place maya says sarcastically
that she thought they were just trying
to justify five more years of seizures
and the truth is likely somewhere in the
middle but it undermines everything she
believed about her job in the end
navarro realizes he doesn't have any
other options he knows he'll likely get
screwed over in the end but he agrees to
the five-year deal the fbi tells marty
and wendy that they'll take over their
role with the cartel and thanks them for
their service to america and they were
just that close to getting out but it
wasn't meant to be javi finds out that
shaw pharmaceuticals was able to make
their production goals even while he was
withholding his product he calls claire
who tells him that marty provided a stop
gap and when pressed gives up ruth's
description things hadn't been going
good for her because darlene found out
that she did the deal with marty and had
also killed frank senior in a rage and
so ruth and wyatt were going to take off
together and she took the opportunity to
tell frank jr about what happened to his
father because wendy contacted social
services and told them about darlene's
heart attack though they were coming to
take zeke and when wyatt found out about
that he wasn't able to leave her he
decided to marry her to keep that from
happening ruth is initially upset
because they were that close to getting
out themselves but she eventually
accepts it and then has to go and tell
frank jr that he can't kill her at the
same time things take a real turn for
the birds when navarro returns to his
plane where he's surrounded by cops and
taken into custody maya went behind her
boss's back and made a move against him
and now there's nothing that they can
really do about it this worries marty
and wendy because they're afraid that
hobby's gonna think that they were
involved because maya was he sends
charlotte to go get jonah and take him
into hiding at buddy's mausoleum and
when she goes to the lazio to pick him
up mel is there and he overhears part of
their conversation while they're hiding
they do have a talk where she tries to
reassure him that they'll always stick
together and that they'll always be fine
marty and wendy are able to get the fbi
to consider a deal with hobby now that
omar is locked up they need him to
contact his nephew and tell him to do it
though and he almost kills marty before
wendy can talk him into it the plan is
that if he makes a deal then navarro
will be extradited to mexico where he
can walk away from all of this before he
leaves he warns that if he isn't out of
jail in 48 hours nelson has orders to
kill them wyatt and darlene have their
wedding at the same time the fbi is
explaining the deal to hobby it's
changed to 10 years of running the
cartel instead of 5 and includes extra
stipulations which all kind of backs up
what maya was saying and we see mel call
her on the phone after he sees her on
the news and tells her that he's a big
fan which hints at a team up in the
second half of the season darlene and
wyatt come home to find hobby waiting in
their living room now that he works for
the fbi he feels emboldened and he
shoots and kills both of them and walks
out leaving zeke crying in the
background ruth was headed over there to
give them their gift and tell them
goodbye and she's the one who discovers
the bodies she grabs zeke and drives
away crying and initially thinks it's
frank jr but when she talks to him and
realizes he didn't do it she heads
straight to the bird's house she demands
to know who killed wyatt and they're
reluctant to say anything now that
they're relying on the deal between the
fbi and hobby in one final act of
rebellion against wendy jonah tells her
and when marty pleads with her not to
get involved with hobby she screams if
you want to stop me you're gonna have to
effing kill me which you have to imagine
wendy is already considered she takes
her shotgun and storms out and gets into
her truck with zeke and takes off the
episode ends with her driving away
thinking about what she's going to do
and then breaking down screaming part
one ends with a pretty big cliffhanger
and the unresolved mystery of the car
crash at the beginning that certainly
hints at the family coming back together
enough that they're ready to get out
again but there's a lot that needs to
happen to get them there if you think
about it ruth really has lost it all now
that she's lost wyatt it's clear that
marty still has a sense of wanting to
look after her but after what happened
with ben there's no chance she's going
to listen to them and who else is there
to talk sense into her after his deal
with the fbi javi's in a powerful
position and it's hard to imagine that
he won't abuse that so a lot of great
stuff to set up the second part where
anything could still happen and the wild
cards of mel and maya still out there to
throw things off post ben wendy has
really turned into the most interesting
character to watch there were so many
points in these episodes where she seems
so absolutely ruthless i liked it when
the birds sort of blackmailed navarro
saying that if anything happens to them
his kids won't be able to access the
money they put aside he actually took
the high road imagine sitting down with
a cartel boss and you come away looking
like the dishonorable one also liked the
twist with the fbi and how they were
portrayed there's a nice parallel with
all the dirt wendy was doing and her
counseling claire telling herself that
she'd be piling good on top of good to
make up for all the bad while at the
same time telling her son who she tried
to get arrested that he needs to grow up
because this is america and no one cares
how you got your fortune the family is
divided and nothing that happened in the
final moment seemed to put jonah and
wendy on the path to reconciliation i
also wonder how jim will feel about
working with the birds after what went
down and what that might mean for the
foundation all things considered things
were progressing on that front and the
fbi did relieve them of their money
laundering duties for the cartel marty
even pulled the trigger on the office in
chicago before they found out about
darlene and wyatt ruth is alone and
wants vengeance and i suppose as we near
the end of the series the question will
be who makes it out it will be
interesting to see how the different
birds approach her situation and where
things will land by the end of part two
and i think that's a good place to leave
things let me know in the comments what
you thought about part one how you think
things are gonna play out and check back
in a couple of days because i'll follow
this up with the second video with all
my questions about part two we're
getting to the end of the series so let
me know what you think's gonna happen
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon